bonsoir les deux messages première fois
et peindre c'est la lumière qui attire
les rappeurs alors fetison vous arrivez
du zénith le concert s'est bien passé
super c'était génial
est-ce que tu as croisé lollobrigida
dans les collèges tu as croisé une dame
âgée avec des bijoux c'est servir
comment comment trouvez-vous le public
français epst il était super il était
david grand une belle présence bien tout
le monde était là pour écouter c'était
génial
je vous aime les gens ici
alors
béatrice dalle bruno béatrice dalle non
non je suis désolé de nos chantiers
coignard
sinon désolé et lui c'est m6 jean gabin
mc jean gab'1 kaki et 1,3 milliard
voilà et m6 baverel m6 bat vreizh nous
allons y arriver
m6 d'avray ce que ce qui paye mon cher
pays qui sert cocaïne
alors vous savez quand même que fifty
sonne c'est le premier rappeur qui a été
signé sur le label de eminem et dr dre
qui s'appelle chats dits oui cordes et
quand vous avez signé le contrat de dr
dre vous a dit es-tu prêt à rentrer dans
l'histoire quand même c'est vrai que
c'est un événement puisque ils vous ont
choisi ils m'ont choisi c'était c'était
un événement ils m'ont dit que l'avenir
lettres nouveau oui ça s'est passé
d'ailleurs alors ils nous ont offert un
million de dollars pour le contrat
vous aviez des offres à un million bulle
6 mais vous avez quand même choisi
eminem et dr dre 1 parce que sur le plan
créatif je pouvais pas obtenir la même
chose pas qu'une question d'argent
oui alors vous avez eu raison de signer
avec eux parce que ça a boosté votre
votre cd et vous en avez vendu six
millions aux usa voilà ça vous plaît
nicolas le hip hop la v5 et budget total
non mais les parkinsoniens c'est
fabuleux si kevin lee mélodique extra
willaya senti avec lui donc c'est
vachement bien
bravo ça vous plaise ou non vous êtes
très chanceux parce qu'il est une
personne jean gabin vous êtes le premier
qu'il aime ce soir on a eu du pot
coup de bol alors on vous appelle
filtisac mais votre vrai nom c'est
qu'artiste jackson vous avez une enfance
difficile dans le queens et dans
l'endroit le plus violent du queens à
new york qui s'appelle saf jamaïca vous
avez élevé là on vote mère sabrina est
décédé à l'âge de 23 ans à l'époque vous
aviez huit ans elle vous avez eu à l'âge
de 15 ans votre mère vendait du crack
est ce que vous mettez à faire
d'ailleurs vous aussi dès l'âge de 12
ans et c'est vrai vous dites en restant
huit ans de plus au bahut j'allais tout
juste pour voir décrocher un job qui me
permettent d'acheter une caisse
d'occasion vous dit le deal n'était pas
une solution c'était la seule solution
c'est grave
alors maintenant ce qui se passe et que
dans certains cas quand on grandit dans
un quartier comme ça quand on n'a pas
d'argent
l'argent semble à peu près impossible
c'est la solution à tous les problèmes
ont trouvé un moyen de trouver sa maman
elle a fait ce qu'il fallait pour les
nourrir alors après la prison quand vous
devenez papa d'un petit garçon
vous prenez un peu vos distances avec le
deal et le milieu du crime et vous
rentrez dans le rap et vous rencontrez
vous avez beaucoup de chance vous
rencontrez jam master jay de reynerie m6
ce qu'on fait la chanson avec aerosmith
et vous faites un premier album qui
s'appelle power of dollars
mais à ce moment là je comprends pas
pourquoi vous commencez vous toucher 250
mille dollars pour faire cet album
et pourtant vous continuez à dix les du
crack comment j'avais effectivement 250
mille dollars sur le contrat mais
l'avant ce n'était que de 65 mille
dollars 5,6 à la sortie de la suite
pour l'avocat pour les juristes enfin
une banque c'est 5000 $ en poche
j'avais deux ou trois vivent pendant un
an et demi ça serait pas mal
et donc c'est pour ça qu'il a fallu
trouver d'autres solutions d'accord
alors on mai 2000 le 24 mai exactement
vous promener dans le quartier du
queen's en jeep
quand un inconnu vous tire dessus avec
un 9 mm et vous prenez 9 balles dans le
corps
vous arrivez malgré tout à conduire
jusqu'à l'hôpital jamaïca
vous savez qui vous attire et ses neuf
balles dans le corps
je n'ai pas personnellement
cela étant ça vient de ma vie avant la
musique
ouais vous avez peur aujourd'hui encore
nous faire tirer dessus
non non non pas du pont neuf balles et
que tu en sors ton n'a rien à regretter
quoi alors voilà donc à ce moment là la
maison de disques columbia refuse de
vous gardez vous retournez dans le drame
vers vos racines et vous rencontrer à ce
moment là voilà le manager de eminem est
là tout va bien c'est un conte de fées
qui commence puisque comme je dédie tout
à l'heure vous en vendez 6 millions 4
mois mais vous avez toujours fermés un
petit peu d'aidé
et il est toujours un peu des
embrouilles avec la police n'ont quand
même malgré tout nord malgré tout
comment peut-on pas de grosses
embrouilles disent oh oui dernièrement
vous avez eu un problème de port d'armes
vous avez un petit problème de port
d'armes vous a été pris dans une autre
en fusillade
et vous savez quand même que quand vous
allez revenir aux états unis vous devez
allez vous présenter à la police quand
même fifty san vous savez ça la police
est toujours en retrait dont d'été avec
des trucs qui sont morts pour un flingue
alors aujourd'hui tout va bien vous
acheter un château il achète un château
pour mettre le crack il achète un
château à deux heures de new york qui
est un très beau château qui était la
demeure de mike tyson s'est est en train
de lâcheté pour quand même quatre
millions d'euros c'est pas mal 4
millions d'euros ça fait combien ton qui
sait compter 26 millions ah oui c'est
bien dit dont elle est belle la maison à
ce prix là non comment attend elle est
comment la maison sérieux au niveau
soixantaine de chambres
vous pourrez à accueillir des amis
instant bien pire
samedi matin je vais jouer à construire
un tiers le valider une idée alors on
écrit un film sur vous aussi le
scénariste des soprano est en train
d'écrire un film sur vous absolument oui
c'est vrai biostar travaillant soit
au-dessus sur un fil qui sera bientôt
tourné
c'est la réussite avec un guide et le
succès des mines m avec le film de
batman ça m'a beaucoup aidé et puis
c'est quand même un lancement et ben non
ils m'aiment bien aussi ouais vous
connaissez le rap français
mais quand une fille française ne parle
jamais béatrice est ce que ça veut dire
ça pue a traduit aussi d'ailleurs du
baston là au plus tard c'est joey starr
le mari de béatrice est très très
méchant il a failli me tuer une fois
qu'il me respecte comme mike tyson mal
conduit tombe bien aussi
oui j'ai oublié dire que je mettais
balcon et c'est vrai oui deux pions se
réconcilier ça va bien merci
kkb match ils couchent et mieux vous
avez pas vous promener dans la ville et
tout ça mais c'est un joueur on va
rentrer sagement la maison merci d'avoir
égalé crise et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu